toute la journée nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de la population à leur
encontre des habitants de données est ce
qui est bien entendu les gens nous
disent qu'ils sont préoccupés par cette
situation préoccupe et parce qu'ils
peuvent lire dans les journaux ou encore
voir à la télévision la presse
occidentale relais en effet depuis des
semaines des informations sur la
soi-disant imminence d'une attaque de la
russie contre l'ukraine mais les gens
craignent davantage une offensive de la
part de kiev que les services de
renseignement russes jugent au passage
plausible car la ligne de front se
trouve simplement à quelques kilomètres
d'ici nous sommes sous pression
constante tous les jours nous entendons
des tirs soit ce sont nos hommes qui
ripostent soit ce sont les autres qui
tire bien sûr on ne peut pas le savoir
avec certitude
on le comprend seulement quand quelque
chose tombe ici à proximité
on reste chez nous bien sûr par exemple
je reste toujours derrière le mur j'ai
la cuisine la salle de par les toilettes
et il y à un mur de l'autre côté je suis
toujours là et quand ça commence je
cours là dans le petit couloir ça fait
très peur j'ai peur pour les enfants
pour les plus vieux j'ai peur pour tout
le monde les autres ont confiance dans
les forces armées des républiques
autoproclamées de donetsk et de lougansk
pour les protéger mais aussi dans celles
de la russie
personnellement je n'ai aucune crainte
car je crois fermement que si un moment
difficile arrive la russie nous aidera
toujours comme elle l'a déjà fait
plusieurs fois et nous avons quand même
de vrais hommes dans l'armée je connais
ses combattants c'est pas comme au début
donc je pense que tout cela n'est qu'une
façade très soigneusement mise en scène
par quelqu'un et que vous savez tout
ressemble à un décor c'est ce qui me
semble en tout cas
donc pas tant nous avons peur parce que
nous élevons des enfants ici ils
apprennent à vivre alors bien sûr nous
avons peur depuis 2014 mais nous croyons
en la russie la russie nous aidera nous
croyons en nos soldats nous espérons le
meilleur chien tama games and en route
même si la vie à donetsk reste calme la
population du nom basse vit depuis des
années au rythme d'une guerre de basse
intensité mais une guerre tout de même
qu'ils continuent de faire régulièrement
des morts et ce à quelques kilomètres
seulement 10,6 et en cas d' escalade
militaire la population sait très bien
qu'elle se retrouvera alors en première
ligne